[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein die ukraine ist näher
an deutschland als manche ziele die wir
schon selbstverständlich als wochenend
trip destinationen abgespeichert haben
berlin kiew das ist kürzer als nach
madrid neapel oder lissabon nur um mal
auch die geografische dringlichkeit klar
zu machen wenn sich heute in berlin
russen und ukrainer an einen tisch
setzen und die deutschen gastgeber
hoffen dass es dabei vorangeht oder
zumindest wenigstens nicht weiter
richtung eskalation auch die spitzen der
drei baltischen staaten sind heute in
berlin sie fühlen sich als direkte
nachbarn von russland bedroht und sie
werden dem bundeskanzler ihre sorgen
klar gemacht haben und dann auf konkrete
antworten hoffen ein tag so sagen die
diplomatischen beobachter auf den man
ganz besonders genau gucken muss für uns
tut dass andreas künast
hinter dem spektakulären mosaik fenster
in der russischen botschaft in berlin
stellen sich diplomaten und journalisten
auf eine lange vielleicht sehr lange
nacht ein russlands medien warten auf
nachricht aus den verhandlungen mit der
ukraine
es gibt tee kaffee und bis jetzt nicht
den leisesten hinweis wie es läuft
hinter der ukrainischen fahne einen
kilometer entfernt wird der
verhandlungsführer aus kiew erwartet ist
heute der krieg näher gerückt oder der
frieden weit weg von den kameras in der
villa borsig am tegeler see haben
deutschland und frankreich die
diplomaten der verfeindeten staaten
zusammen gebracht den ängsten
außenpolitischen berater von präsident
putin dmitri kosak und andrea marx den
engsten berater von präsident sei lenski
es ist das zweite treffen im sogenannten
normandie format seit beginn des
russischen truppenaufmarsch es wäre das
erste das etwas bringt in dieser für uns
alle kritischen situationen sollte
russland unsere einigkeit und
entschlossenheit nicht unterschätzen als
partner in der eu und das verbündete in
der nato dass ausgerechnet der deutsche
kanzler einigkeit und geschlossenheit
beschwört nehmen die verbündeten in der
nato mit nur ein ganz klein wenig spott
zur kenntnis als boris johnson in
brüssel nach der einheit des westens
gefragt wird fällt ihm als erstes
deutschland ein
ich gratuliere olaf scholz dass er in
der lage war sich in richtung einer
härteren position zur nord stream zwei
zu bewegen so schwierig das für die
deutsche wirtschaft auch ist
deutschland bemüht sich die dellen zu
glätten kanzler scholz sendet am abend
ein weiteres solidarität signal und
empfängt die premierministerin von
estland den ministerpräsidenten von
lettland und den präsidenten von litauen
die baltischen staaten und deutschland
seite an seite falls es immer noch
kritik an der bundesregierung gibt dann
nicht heute
dank deutschland für die entscheidung
350 zusätzliche soldaten zu schicken ein
freund in der not ist ein wahrer freund
der einzige weg mit dem kreml zu
verhandeln ist aus einer position der
stärke nicht aus einer position der
schwäche
zwischen berlin und allen ligen viele
kilometer aber unsere sicherheit ist
gemeinsam und unteilbar
berlin wartet heute nacht ob es neue
signale aus russland gibt oder neue
signale aus der ukraine
die deutsche regierung versucht eine
doppelstrategie scholz droht russland
mit schwerwiegenden konsequenzen und
erklärt sich gleichzeitig zu einem
ernsthaften gespräch bereit
caracas ist die ministerpräsidentin von
estland dass sich auch selbst besonders
bedroht fühlt durch den russischen
militär aufmarsch vor
ministerpräsidentin buch durchs guten
abend
was haben sie denn heute vom
bundeskanzler gehört dass sie jetzt
möglicherweise unbesorgt da schlafen
lässt
gute verbündete und was wir heute gehört
haben ist das ist die einheit der nato
dem bundeskanzler sehr sehr wichtig ist
das ist eine gute botschaft bevor er
nach moskau ist alles über das wir also
vorher gesprochen haben
dass wir also keinerlei zugeständnisse
machen in bezug auf die
sicherheitsstruktur europas ist ganz
wichtig und wird bestand haben sie sagen
keinerlei zugeständnisse zu machen da
frag ich gleich mal was was machen denn
dann überhaupt verhandlungen mit
russland für einen sinn wenn sie von
vornherein sagen keinerlei
zugeständnisse oder anders gefragt was
können sie denn wladimir putin anbieten
das ist schon eine falle diese frage zu
stellen wir können ein gespräch führen
mit russland ein dialog wir sollten
keiner der verhandlung führen
putin
hat hier diese militärpräsenz an der
ukrainischen grenze aufgebaut und man
kann ja keine verhandlung mit thema
führen der die pistole auf die brust
setzt und die frage zu fragen was wir
russland anbieten sollen ist schon eine
volle die nato stellt ja keine gefahr da
wir bauen kein druck auf wir haben keine
waffen an die grenze der russischen
präsenz geschaffen und bedrohen russland
nicht also wenn man hier schon auf ein
diktator reagiert der allem die pistole
auf die brust setzt dann würde man ja
schon von vornherein ein einknicken und
somit die sicherheit europas gefährden
sie sagen die frage ist bereits eine
falle aber man muss ja die frage stellen
wie man irgendwie am ende friedlich aus
der ganzen sache wieder rauskommt da
muss ja dann um irgendwie dass diese
verhandlungen am ende erfolg haben auch
dem russischen präsidenten ein
gesichtswahrende lösung angeboten werden
oder etwa nicht
wien tätig welches strategische geduld
mit russland diese strategie
dieser
verhandlungstaktik russlands erinnert
mich an den ehemaligen
aussenminister der sowjetunion der drei
dinge gesagt hat er hat gesagt erst mal
die maximale forderung stellen nicht
einfach nur was france oder um das
becken sondern einfach was fordern was
dir vorher nicht gehört hat zweitens ein
ultimatum stellen und drittens keinen
zentimeter nachgeben bei verhandlungen
denn es wird immer im westen
irgendwelche leute geben die dir was
anbieten werden was du vorher nicht
hattest das heißt nach diesen gesprächen
würdest du ein drittel oder die hälfte
dessen haben was du gefordert hast das
hat er damals gesagt und das müssen wir
bedenken
strategische geduld üben während wir
gespräche führen mit russland und
niemals das große bild aus den augen
verlieren ihre klaren warnungen heute
abend und ihre erfahrung und die sie
gerade geschildert haben aus der
vergangenheit haben sie den eindruck das
ist beim bundeskanzler angekommen ist ja
nächste woche in moskau wladimir putin
es will ja er war ganz ganz klar in
seinen botschaften in seinen aussagen
hat er ganz klar gesagt dass keinerlei
zugeständnisse gemacht werden er
wird diese einheit auf jeden fall
fördern und waren das ist ganz wichtig
jetzt hat irland estland ja von
deutschland die genehmigung erbeten alte
artilleriegeschütze noch aus ddr
beständen an die ukraine liefern zu
dürfen
deutschland prüft das jetzt und zwar
seit wochen erwarten sie da noch eine
positive antwort
unsere
verteidigungsministerien sprechen
darüber ich sage natürlich dass
deutschland jedes recht hat zu
entscheiden wie deutschland der ukraine
helfen möchte wie ein estland haben
beschlossen dass kra ine mit allen
möglichkeiten die wir haben unterstützen
möchten auch mit verteidigungswaffen
aber deutschland oder auch etwas anderes
land hat das recht zu entscheiden was
das jeweilige land machen möchte und
deutschland leistet sehr viel zur
unterstützung der ukraine finanziell und
auch wirtschaftlich weil dieser export
frage die ich gerade angesprochen habe
scheint dann aber deutschland noch
weiter auf der bremse zu stehen was was
wie kommt das bei ihnen an
wir haben noch keine offizielle antwort
von der bundesrepublik erhalten aber wie
gesagt deutschland hat das recht
eigene entscheidung zu treffen
es steht ja uns nicht an deutschland zu
sagen was es tun kann oder nicht tun
kann wir versuchen unsere rolle zu
spielen wir machen unsere eigenen
entscheidungen und die bundesrepublik
trifft ihre entscheidung das liegt an
der bundesrepublik hier ihre eigenen
entscheidungen zu treffen sagt sie
diplomatisch die ministerpräsidentin von
estland chor colours hat sich ein dank
für das gespräch heute abend
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen um 21 uhr aufgezeichnet
ein gefährlicher moment für europa
sicherheit sagt heute der
nato-generalsekretär düstere worte aus
brüssel sein gast der britische premier
sagt sogar europa stehe der
gefährlichste moment bevor in der
größten sicherheits krise für den
kontinent seit jahrzehnten
der russische militär aufmarsch hört
nicht auf im gegenteil die marine bringt
weitere kriegsschiffe ins schwarze meer
und auch im nördlichen nachbarland der
ukraine in belarus macht russland mobil
offiziell sind das militär übungen
gemeinsam mit belarus die truppen sollen
laut kreml danach auch wieder abziehen
auffällig allerdings wo diese manöver
stattfinden nämlich schwerpunktmäßig an
der grenze zur ukraine
axel sturm mit mehr dazu
das russische militär video team hat
sogar eine drohne nach belarus
mitgebracht um die schlagkraft der
eigenen truppen in szene zu setzen von
heute an zehn tage lang werden sich
diese bilder wiederholen scheingefechte
kampfjets am himmel
raketensysteme
wir beobachten die russischen kräfte in
belarus sehr genau es ist die grösste
truppen ansammlung seit ende des kalten
krieges dies ist ein gefährlicher moment
für die europäische sicherheit
aus moskau und minsk heißt es hier werde
auf einen imaginären eindringling
geschossen die nato sagt russland habe
inzwischen rund 30.000 soldaten in
belarus eine weitere drohkulisse im
ukraine konflikt es sind aber auch
kriegsspiele unter freunden und stumpfe
machtpolitik zweier älterer herren der
eine lukaschenko braucht den anderen
schlicht für das eigene politische
überleben dem anderen putin nutzt das um
sich im westen gehör zu verschaffen
[Musik]
faktisch ist belarus der einzige
verbündete russlands in diesem konflikt
und solange lukaschenko auf jegliche
weise die bereitschaft demonstriert
moskau in diesem konflikt zu
unterstützen so lange gewährt russland
belarus im gegenzug jegliche
unterstützung
es steckt mehr drin in diesem manöver
als der ukraine konflikt es geht auch um
zwei präsidenten die ihre staaten
abwenden vom westen zum bild gehört auch
fast tägliches werben mahnen drohen
gerne vor ort in moskau in dieser rolle
heute bläst rus britische
außenministerin das lief sagen wir
durchwachsen
russland hat eine klare wahl sie können
den vater diplomatie beschreiten mit der
nato zusammenarbeiten um die europäische
sicherheit zu verbessern oder sie
bleiben auf dem pfad den sie andeuten
indem sie in einer bedrohlichen art
massenhaft truppen an der grenze
stationieren
ehrlich gesagt ich bin enttäuscht wir
hatten ein gespräch zwischen einem
tauben und einem stummen
das alles sieht aus wie eine einseitige
forderung die auf dem unerschütterlichen
basiert dass der westen das recht habe
von uns irgendwelche garantien zu
fordern in einer situation in der uns
niemand garantien geben möchte
auch die armee der ukraine trainierte
heute blizzard heißt die übung im süden
bei person
und gundula cook jetzt auf die deutsche
außenministerin die heute in einem
anderen konflikt unterwegs ist der
bereits ihre vorgänger allesamt in atem
gehalten hat ja seit 2014 liegt der
nahost-friedensprozess brach aus
ministerin baerbock hat israel und die
palästinenser nun zur wiederaufnahme der
gespräche aufgerufen deutschland sei
bereit beide seiten zu unterstützen
sagte sie auch palästinenserpräsident
abbas zu zuvor hatte israels
ministerpräsident benjamin
ist er in kritisierte zugleich israels
siedlungsbau beim besuch der holocaust
gedenkstätte jad vaschem rief baerbock
zum entschlossenen kampf gegen
antisemitismus auf zu den crooner zahlen
in deutschland die weiter steigen das
robert koch institut meldet eine höhere
hospitalisierung inzidenz von aktuell
6,23 und
1862 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
elf 1742 mehr als vor einer woche
238 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage inzidenz steigt auf
1465 4 in paris hat die polizei geplante
straßenblockaden gegen korona maßnahmen
verboten am wochenende sollte es in der
französischen hauptstadt trucker demos
geben im internet organisiert nach
kanadischem vorbild
derweil dauern die lkw proteste in
kanadas hauptstadt ottawa und an
grenzübergängen zu den usa an die
kanadische und die us regierung zeigen
sich zunehmend besorgt die blockade sei
eine gefahr für die erholung der
wirtschaft
bei protesten gegen die strengen kroner
maßnahmen in neuseeland sind in der
hauptstadt wellington
120 menschen festgenommen worden zuvor
war es zu zusammenstößen mit der polizei
gekommen
die hatte versucht ein protestcamp vor
dem parlament zu räumen tausende
menschen waren seit dienstag dorthin
gezogen um gegen die impfpflicht für
bestimmte berufsgruppen zu demonstrieren
mit scharfer kritik hat
bundesinnenministerium feser auf die
andauernde blockaden von autobahnen
durch klimaaktivisten reagiert
friedlicher protest sei in der
demokratie zwar wichtig aber niemand
habe das recht andere zu gefährden seit
gut zwei wochen blockieren aktivisten
immer wieder autobahnen und
verkehrsknotenpunkte um
klimafreundlichere gesetze durchzusetzen
verständnis kam von
bundesumweltministerin lämpel es sei
legitim formen des zivilen ungehorsams
zu nutzen
er nannte die erinnerung an den
holocaust einen zitat schuldkult und
wird vom verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem ist eingestuft er war
bundestagsabgeordneter der af dem und
will jetzt wieder zurück in sein
früheres amt als richter in sachsen es
geht um den fall jens maier der
mittlerweile nicht nur der sächsischen
justiz kopfschmerzen bereitet sondern
auch der politik es geht um
rückkehrrecht und dienstvorgesetzte im
ermessensspielraum und
disziplinarverfahren und jenseits aller
bürokratischen wortungetüme um viel mehr
als das um unseren rechtsstaat cornelia
schiemenz
es war der tag der bundestagswahl als
sich die afg über zehn direktmandate in
sachsen freute und der sächsichen
justizministerin dämmerte dass da ein
riesenproblem auf sie zukommt
natürlich hat mir das auch schon die
eine oder andere eher mehr als weniger
schlaflose nächte bereitet sozusagen mit
dem tag der bundestagswahl
jens maier heißt der mann der für
schlaflose nächte der ministerin sorgt
denn wegen der vielen sächsischen
direktmandate verpasste er trotz
listenplatz zwei den wiedereinzug in den
bundestag und will nun wieder als
richter im freistaat arbeiten das darf
nicht sein heißt es mit ausnahme der afg
fraktion unisono im dresdner landtag
seine ganzen politischen äußerungen die
auch außerhalb des bundestages gemacht
hat sind mehr als starke tendenzen zu
einer rechtsradikalen position und zu
einer abkehr der freiheitlichen
grundordnung und deswegen kann jemand
wie jens meyer aus unserer sicht und das
politischer verantwortung auch in diesem
land nicht mehr richter und echt
sprechen
der sächsische verfassungsschutz stuft
jens maier als rechtsextrem 1 führt ihn
als obmann des rechtsradikalen und
inzwischen aufgelösten flügels der afd
2017 diffamierte meyer die
erinnerungskultur
das abgeordnetengesetz gibt
parlamentariern ein rückkehrrecht und
das bringt die sächsische justiz
ministerin nun in die zwickmühle denn
katja meier muss entscheiden wie es mit
jens maier weitergeht sie habe alles
prüfen lassen und keine handhabe so sagt
sie ich kann und werde nicht riskieren
dass ein disziplinarverfahren am ende
vor dem gericht keinen bestand hat nur
weil es diesen politischen druck gibt
die justiz ministerin würde den ball
gerne weiterspielen in den sächsischen
landtag hier prüfen linke und grüne
gerade die möglichkeit einer richter
anklage die bräuchte aber eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und die regierende
cdu lehnt ab er kehrt vom bundestag
zurück hat keine arbeit will wieder
zurück stellt den antrag dann ist die
dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde sprich das
justizministerium zuständig und dann
kann das justizministerium sagen komm zu
mir in die behörde und dann arbeitest du
bei mir und dann ist ja kein richter am
richter am landgericht und damit ist die
sache erledigt
erledigt wird die sache so schnell nicht
sein davon ist richter ruben franzen
überzeugt schnelles handeln ist in der
justiz immer schwierig weil schnell
handeln
dann in der regel verfahrensvorschriften
außer acht lässt wer darf recht sprechen
in einem rechtsstaat der fall jens meier
ist ein novum in der deutschen
geschichte es gibt keine blaupause und
genau deswegen ist er eine
herausforderung für eben diesen
rechtsstaat
und wir machen noch einmal nachrichten
denn in sachen energiepolitik kommen
gewaltige nachrichten aus frankreich die
einzuordnen sind angesichts der tatsache
dass deutschland einen anderen weg geht
um den ausbau der solarenergie in
deutschland voranzubringen will die
bundesregierung
photovoltaik-anlagen auf ackerflächen
künftig bezuschussen das planen die drei
grün geführten ministerien für
wirtschaft umwelt und landwirtschaft und
sicherten zu belange des naturschutzes
zu berücksichtigen der bauernverband
kritisierte die pläne nehmen zu wenig
rücksicht auf die landwirtschaft und
auch frankreich plant den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien bis 2050 will
präsident makro dutzende windparks vor
der französischen küste bauen lassen und
strebt eine verdoppelung der
erneuerbaren energien an zugleich aber
kündigte makronen beim besuch eines
energiekonzerns eine renaissance der
kernkraft in frankreich an bis 2050 will
makro sechs moderne reaktoren bauen und
acht weitere prüfen lassen die kernkraft
sei für ihn unverzichtbarer baustein der
energiewende
deutschland hält dagegen am atomausstieg
fest frank bethmann und importiert
zugleich kernkraft eben aus frankreich
ja das wird auch erst mal so bleiben bei
der energiewende trennen beide staaten
wählten deutschland benötigt zugekauften
atomstrom aus frankreich noch zur
überbrückung für die franzosen ist die
kernkraft viel mehr als nur eine brücke
ein wichtiger wirtschaftsfaktor mit
hunderttausenden von arbeitsplätzen und
entsprechende investitionen geld
neuerdings so vereinbarte es jüngst die
eu sogar als klimafreundlich da passt
dass der vom französischen staat
dominierte versorger edf heute bekannt
gab einen teil des kernenergie
geschäftes des us konzerns general
electric übernehmen zu wollen auf rund
eine milliarde dollar wird der wert des
deals geschätzt auch bei siemens gab es
zeiten da spielte das kernkraftgeschäft
eine große rolle inzwischen nicht mehr
dass siemens von heute und morgen
verdient sein geld in dem es auto oder
batteriefabriken oder halbleiter anlagen
mit siemens-technik ausrüstet die
auftragseingänge geschossen zuletzt in
ungeahnte höhen man komme mit der
produktion kaum hinterher hieß es heute
auf der virtuellen hauptversammlung die
siemens aktie heute deutlich im plus der
dax nicht kaum verändert bei 15.000 490
punkten zuvor aber war er mächtig
eingeknickt nachdem die usa für januar
eine inflation von siebeneinhalb prozent
gemeldet hatten steigende inflation wird
in der regel mit steigenden zinsen
bekämpft die wiederum aktienmärkte nicht
so gerne mögen frank bethmann vielen
dank der berliner lieferdienste livery
war heute auch börsen thema um mehr als
30 prozent stürzte die aktie 1 auf den
tiefsten stand seit april 2020 das
unternehmen enttäuschte mit seinen
geschäftszahlen zwar stieg der umsatz
trotzdem schreibt lewe regierung noch
rote zahlen
er ist schwarz gut 555 karat schwer und
hat jetzt für umgerechnet 3,8 millionen
euro den besitzer gewechselt enigma der
größte geschliffene diamant der je bei
einer auktion versteigert wurde
sotheby's hatte den seltenen edelstein
vor der online auktion als kosmisches
wunde angepriesen experten vermuten dass
er vor mehr als 2 6 milliarden jahren
durch den einschlag eines meteoriten
oder asteroiden auf der erde
entstanden ist
der rote teppich funktioniert online
eher schlecht als video call event wird
die feierliche premiere irgendwie
glanzlos überhaupt die magie des films
bilder und geschichten die einen im
besten fall nie wieder loslassen diese
magie braucht einen großen saal eine
große leinwand sie braucht das rascheln
und lachen und weinen und küssen was man
halt im kino so macht andererseits ist
deutschlands größtes filmfest schon in
nicht pandemie zeiten berüchtigt dafür
eine virenschleuder zu sein ich sag nur
berlin februar nieselregen wer am ende
einer berlinale keinen schnupfen hat war
nicht richtig dabei was also tun die
festivalleitung hat sich entschieden
vorhang auf und die filmfans sind
gekommen hat ja nasa ein wenig glamour
gegen die korona tristes viele deutsche
stars sind an den potsdamer platz
gekommen um auf dem roten teppich flagge
zu zeigen für das kino auch wenn diese
berlinale im pandemie zeiten anders ist
als sonst weniger filme halb so viele
zuschauer keine partys und hollywood
kommt diesmal gar nicht aber wer hier
ist der will das kino feiern wenn auch
nicht ganz unbeschwert
ist ein gutes zeichen
aber ich merke mir selber dass ich schon
mal vor freudiger war da auch in folge
nein habe ich überlegt hin und her ja
oder nein hingehen oder nicht und jetzt
wenig so cool wir brauchen wieder ort
die uns wieder zusammenführen wir haben
so viel und so lange zeit alleine war 18
filme konkurrieren vor der
internationalen jury um die silbernen
und den goldenen bären in vielen davon
dreht sich alles um die liebe auch bei
françois brousse der französische
regisseur eröffnet den wettbewerb mit
peter von kant eine neufassung des
klassikers von rainer werner fassbinder
die bitteren tränen der petra von kant
kinos film verliebt sich der alternde
filmemacher peter unsterblich in den
jungen amir will ihn groß rausbringen
ein dichtes kammerspiel das sich
ausschließlich in peter von kants vier
wänden abspielt
die idee zu diesem film hatte ich im
lock down ich war damals nicht sicher ob
und wie je wieder einen film drehen kann
durch die pandemie gab es so viele
einschränkungen
man konnte ja keine szenen mehr drehen
mit vielen menschen und da habe ich an
diesem großartigen film von fassbinder
denken müssen seine petra von kant
spielt ja nur in einem zehn orten
doch das coaching zuschauer
ordnung in fassbinders film von
1972 ist es eine frau die modeschöpferin
petra die sich unsterblich verliebt ich
liebe dich ich dich auch
richtig auch in die junge karin gespielt
von hanna schygulla die damals ein
skandal her
schygulla ist auch in der neufassung
wieder dabei wollte aber wegen corona
nicht nach berlin kommen trotz aller
einschränkungen durch die pandemie die
72 berlinale will vor allem eins sich
stark machen für das kino
ja auf jeden fall und damit sagen wir
danke leute und weisen noch auf unser
heute-journal update hin um 0.45 mit
nasa aktivieren was macht deutschland da
gerade in der pandemie fragt maybrit
illner jetzt ihre runde unter anderem
den bundesjustizminister und eine
dänische politikwissenschaftlerin ist
das alles teil einer exit strategie oder
ein planloser wettlauf ums öffnet das
demnächst im zdf programm wie sand kies
und bis morgen
[Musik]
ein abend vorübergehend wird jetzt ein
bisschen kälter das liegt an den tiefs
isar 1 und tanja lack fürs wochenende
aber wird dann das hoch ingo
verantwortlich seien nämlich für
sonnenschein in mitteleuropa vorerst
aber ziehen noch regen und vor allen
dingen auch schneewolken über uns hinweg
und morgen wird es deutlich kälter sein
als zuletzt heute nacht geht der regen
zunächst hier in den nördlichen
mittelgebirgen mehr und mehr in schnee
über bis zum frühen morgen schneit es
dann aber auch in süddeutschland morgen
vormittag schneit es noch am längsten am
alpenrand dann gibt es kräftige schnee
regen und graupelschauer vielleicht auch
mal gewitter die vor allen dingen über
den osten ziehen machen sie sich heute
nacht auf gefährlich glatte straßen
gefasst am ehesten trocken bleibt es
ganz im norden und ganz im süden die
schneefallgrenze liegt so etwa 500 meter
die temperaturen sinken auf plus 4 bis
minus 3 grad das reicht also eigentlich
überall für glätte und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen nur noch bei 2 grad
in den östlichen mittelgebirgen und am
alpenrand sonst werden vier bis acht
grad erreichen der mildesten wird es
dabei am rhein am längsten schneiders
morgen vormittag noch an den alpen sonst
sind etliche schauer unterwegs am
nachmittag aber lässt der schneefall am
alpenrand mehr und mehr nach es gibt
noch weitere schauer und an der
nordseeküste da zeigt sich schon sehr
schön die sonne bei nordwest wird am
samstag bekommen wir dann viel
sonnenschein bei 2 bis 8 grad am sonntag
wird es von nordwesten schon wie der
etwas wechselhafter mit regen und
deutlich milder genannt